I was looking for the duck earlier
let's play a London
here are my two ducks
big thanks to Andrew who sent me both of
these
actually the smaller duck came with like
a few dozen others
okay I'm gonna mix up the opening Knight
C3
it's kind of now like a jobava London
and with this move order
usually the knights already on F6
but with Knight on C6 I guess it's a
little bit different
I prepared this at some point
in the past
it's been a while though
so there's a line takes takes
and I haven't looked at this in like at
least a couple months
there is actually kind of a cool trap
here which I will okay now now I can
explain the cool trap is
that Queen A5 is losing
and I had this it may have been in like
a title Tuesday or something
or one of these GCC qualifiers but Queen
A5 is a losing move because of B4
I was just trying to remember the line
but I'm pretty sure after Queen B4
there's Queen D5
if I lose the bishop there's Rook T1
I still have to calculate like Queen C7
Bishop B5
ah then B6 wait how is it winning
Queen before Queen D5 Queen F4
I'm almost certain Queen D5 is a move
or do you want Queen C7
remember analyzing this on stream oh
Queen C7 I just take the pawn
okay
it's one of those cases where like I
remember enough
to kind of figure things out like I I
forgot
I forgot the exact sign
but uh I I knew the the tool set like I
know the combination of this and this
just had to figure out the execution
um so calculation is Queen takes F4
and then then there is an idea Queen D2
but Rook D1 not only prevents Queen D2
it turns mate
and um
I think this game will be over in the
next
maybe two to four moves
unless black wants to play on down the
queen
but yeah after Queen
so I was calculating Queen C7 Bishop B5
D6 but it's important after Queen C7 I
just take the pawn
and then there's a double threat maybe
triple threat of promoting and also this
okay I will admit I
I have not seen this move ever but I
think there's a really cool line
[Music]
oh there's a really cool line
I'm in the side okay
wait does it work I think it works
oh no my queen
someone call an ambulance
and when Bishop takes Queen it defends
The Rook through x-ray vision
also if black doesn't take the queen I'm
mating
and the ambulance probably won't arrive
in time
can I oh I wanted to I wanted it to play
out
because what could have happened
wait wait no no no no pause
let me show the line what could have
happened
was okay I take I say oh no my queen
after Bishop takes Queen
I take I say oh no my queen again
and then Bishop B5 is just amazing
I'm so sad
that would have been a a double oh no my
queen like back to back Queen sacks even
though this
I guess it's still a queen sack right
that's a very short-lived Queen
existing for like one ply
I wonder if this has like happened
before
Bishop E6 played twice
okay once in the game I just played
yeah there's one game
uh Bishop B5 is also playable yeah this
is also winning but this is just easier
right
okay a lot of winning things
I was not immediately made because of
the king can move to D7
that's a cool line though
um
yeah I was studying this in preparation
for like some tournament games
uh this Knight C3 move
and yeah Queen A5
is just a blunder right
and queen A5 looks very natural but
after B4
it's uh it's much much better for
weights
I think Queen G5 is the only winning
move
yeah it's like the only mover the
tactics work out for white
the main line is Queen D1 Queen D1 Rook
D1
takes
and then then there's actually a cool
idea in this position
[Music]
to play Bishop C7
threatening mates
and then
like if Bishop D7 and then there's this
and that Bishop B7 and there's a crazy
idea H4 idea after it takes Rook H3 to
B3
and then the bishop sometimes can get
stuck so just a tidbit of the
preparation for white in this line